Doc Rivers was saying that Clippers
should have taken you on that night who
did you feel like you were going to go
to did you have any idea yeah people
actually asked me about that a lot they
asked me if I'm like better or hold a
grudge towards the Clippers I knew I
wasn't going to the clippers because it
was their doctor who actually wrote the
report that I may never play again he
was the main one who evaluated me and
was like yeah his injuries he may never
play basketball again he sent that whole
memo out to the league I knew they
weren't taking me but like it wasn't
really a goal of mine to prove them
wrong because at that time I was just
like man I hope someone gives me a
chance and then hopefully like I can
work through these injuries and be a
good player again I was really just a
overall like scary time that time I had
no clue you know what I mean I was
trying to put on a hard face but it like
deep down like I had no idea if I was
gonna be able to work through that